You never fail to amaze me, little one.
You are the one they call Iron Man.
I expected more.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
This will be my full Marvel
What If Season 2 Episode 4 Video
There are a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes and gear up for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet.
But this is basically meant to be a season one episode.
Like they planned this.
They did most of the episodes, they recorded
all the voiceover dialog, but for whatever reason
they just did not finish it in time to release it
during season one.
So they just held it,
and then waited the season two to release it.
It's meant to be the episode that leads to that
Episode nine, scene of Iron Man and Gamora,
destroying their universe's version
of the Infinity Gantlet in atomizing their universe.
This version of the Infinity Stones.
So basically this episode was like the season
one missing episode they played the Speedrun version
of the Marvel Studios intro that they've been playing
in most of the episodes so far.
But they played the traditional Marvel Studios fanfare.
It's also a speedrun version of that, like super quick,
then the Watcher basically does
a previously on from season one
to explain how this episode connects with season one.
Like,
this is all the missing stuff that you didn't see, like
how Gamora wound up on that multiverse Avengers team.
then this season.
One scene on Supreme Strange because we're actually
going to see him again by the end of season two.
He'll return for their new Multiverse Avengers team
that they put together for a new threat.
we get a brand new flashback though, of young Gamora
in Thanos because they reference
her being the daughter of Thanos.
Many times in this episode
they blend the Gamora scene with the what if intro,
kind of like they did during episode three with Happy
Hogan Freak like the Purple Happy Hogan Hulk.
just like episode three, the rest of this intro
is the exact same as all the other.
What if intros?
I've already done a much longer breakdown of all
the Easter eggs and references in all these years.
There are many of them
So we'll link that below in the description.
If you want to learn about all the different references
in this particular intro.
as you probably guessed,
it's not Robert Downey Jr doing the Voice of Iron Man,
it's MC Wingard who plays Iron Man.
He also played him during episode three.
He played him during season one as well.
So much for staying for one drink.
you're doing the thing.
He's doing the thing I think the main reason
why Robert Downey Jr didn't come back
is also the same reason
why Chris Evans didn't come back to do Captain America
just because after Avengers Endgame,
they wanted a break from Marvel
and when they developed the
What If series, it was a little too fresh.
there's been all kinds of reports
and rumors about them coming back.
Like Kevin vaguely said, they're not going
to bring the main 616 Iron Man back to life.
So if he does come back in, the MCU is going to be like
a multiverse version of the character.
Then the watcher
explains how things went differently
in this particular universe, Iron Man, and never
wound up making it back through the Qatari portal
at the end of the first Avengers movie
after destroying their fleet with a nuclear warhead,
the portal transports them to Saga
kind of the same way
the Thor winds up getting transported to Sarkar
during Thor Ragnarok In the episode is basically
an alternate version of the plot of Thor Ragnarok,
but Iron Man instead of Thor,
with the time dilation effect, the Sarkar experience
is like time moves differently on Sarkar.
It's only been about a week
or so after the ending of the first Avengers movie
when he arrives on planet
so most of Marvel phase two has not happened yet.
Like the events of Iron Man,
three are still a few months away in the timeline.
He's not on Sarkar that long either.
and even though he eventually goes to help destroy
Thanos with Gamora, they destroyed their universes
version of the Infinity Gantlet.
They atomized their infinity stones.
all that stuff still winds up happening
before the events of Iron Man three would pick up.
So he's not gone from Earth that long.
they kind of implied during season one when the watcher
comes to collect more and bring her to the multiverse
Avengers team that he was going to return
Tony Stark to Earth or allow him to return to Earth.
so the idea is theoretically
a different version of Iron Man three
could still play out for this Iron Man in his universe.
But Avengers Infinity War won't happen in his universe
because there is no more Thanos.
He's dead.
There's no infinity gantlet,
No more infinity stones that exist in a form
that people can actually use
so they're no longer a threat.
so whatever the next Avengers movie winds up
being in that universe, it won't be Avengers Age of
Ultron either, because Ultron was created from the mind
stone in the can't really use the mind stone anymore.
So they can't create Ultron.
this is like a completely different direction
that those Avengers movies take in that universe.
so you can let me know in the comments
who you want to be the next big villain
of that universe version of the Avengers movies.
It probably wind up being the Celestials
because they actually explain during the Eternals movie
that Thanos, by snapping hacked the Universe way
delayed the emergence so Tiamat didn't emerge
for another five years, so that would've just happened
much sooner in the timeline.
So to imagine all of the Avengers battling this giant
celestial is trying to break out of the earth
that Iron Man
literally crashes into the Grand Master,
giving the episode its name, Iron
Man makes a joke about God, even though technically
Tony Stark is meant to be an atheist,
he understands the concept of actual gods
existing in the Marvel universe.
Like Thor is an actual God. But.
He rationalizes them as more advanced aliens.
Like, your celestial being with a lot of power
that just thinks of yourself as a god
most of the other characters
came back to voice their characters,
with a few exceptions,
like Jeff Goldblum came back to do his character.
Topaz came back from Thor Ragnarok
to voice her character
all the grand Masters troops here
and a lot of the design language
on the car, like the buildings,
the energy designs are all based on Jack Kirby
celestial designs
mixed with some Maori Aboriginal New Zealander designs.
When he references going to hell,
hell is actually just another dimension inside the MCU.
We actually saw it during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
Is he in America?
Chavez briefly travel through it
when they're on their trip across the multiverse
within the MCU, within the Marvel Universe,
Mephisto rules that dimension.
He's supposed to be played by Sacha Baron Cohen
during the Ironheart series.
I don't know where else we'll see the character.
Maybe they wind up doing a triumph and torment story
with Doctor Doom in Doctor Strange.
they make a ton of references to TV shows and movies
during this, like Iron Man makes a Lost in space
TV show reference after this,
The Grandmaster reveals that he's become famous
since the events of the Avengers movie when he defeated
the Qatari and calls him Metal Mojo Man.
Like everybody across
the universe knows about what he did.
he's been called Tin Man before.
But the Rocket Man is an Elton John reference.
They make a Wizard of Oz reference,
which the Grandmaster pays off
at the end of the episode when he gets hit
with the melting stick going for Wicked Witch,
making a reference to that movie
revealing that he's actually seen the movie.
That's how he knows to make the reference.
when he says he's only 21 years old,
obviously that's a lie.
But he's an elder of the universe,
one of the oldest living humanoids in the universe.
Literally, he's not as old as a celesta is,
but he's way older than most other humanoids
they explain right now
he's using the contest of champions
with these crazy battle races
which are based on the races in Alita Battle
Angel with the hot Rod and Mad Max looking cards
where everybody's trying to win.
But killing other contestants is totally legal.
Tessa Thompson came back to do the voice of Valkyrie.
She'd been here for a long time.
When Thor eventually shows up
during the events of Thor Ragnarok
and part of the idea here is that the Grandmaster
just changes the type of competition that they have
in the contest of champions periodically in the race,
just what they're doing at the moment.
eventually they would have gone back to regular
gladiator combat.
By the time they got to the events of Thor Ragnarok,
had things gone more like they did in the MCU.
They remind you
that Korg had also been here for a while.
Taika Waititi comes back to voice his character,
thank you for indulging,
because I've always wanted to walk very slowly.
Grandmaster sings
a version of It's My Party and I'll cry if I want to.
Implying that he also knows more about Earth culture.
Just in general,
he makes a lot of Earth based culture references,
so he's probably visited Earth
at some point in his history.
during the episode,
they play a lot of music from Thor Ragnarok,
Iron Man makes a bunch of Formula
One and NASCAR racing references,
which is a bit of a callback to Iron Man two
because he raced in that Formula One car.
When the crowd starts throwing tin cans at Valkyrie,
he says they used to throw rotten food instead.
That's a bit of a callback to actual gladiator combat
In ancient Greece of the Coliseum.
People used to throw stuff at the gladiators.
Sometimes these are throwing chinchillas
which they treat kind of like tribbles in the episode.
Like they're all over the place on Sakaar reveal
his current champion
is a cross between an elephant and a massive
like just a giant creature.
He's got a couple of them too,
but court calls this one Snuppy.
So apparently it's special.
they introduce Kimura,
who winds up showing up inadvertently saving Iron Man
so that she can bring him back to Thanos alive
because Thanos wants to be the one to kill him.
the whole idea is that she winds up on planet
because she'd been tracking
Iron Man across the universe
after he destroyed the Qatari fleet.
and things basically play out the way they did
during Thor Ragnarok with the Grandmaster
using the controlled ships to subdue them.
they make a joke about Iron Man and Gamora hooking up
in Korea, watching Total pervert and as you could
probably tell, it was not Zoe Saldana
doing the Voice of Gamora, it was Cynthia McWilliams.
I'm not sure why she didn't come back to do her voice.
I'm assuming Zoe
Saldana was just busy doing the Avatar movies
because they're filming those back to back.
she makes a reference to Thanos.
Balancing the universe perfectly balanced is all things
should be A bunch of daughter of Thanos references.
He makes a reference to The Island of Dr.
Moreau in The Hunger Games.
So apparently The Hunger Games
are now canon to the MCU as well.
then the reason he's still using that bracelet form
his armor is because this is happening before Iron Man
three, and that's when he started developing his armors
That did not require the special bracelet anymore.
And eventually he'll develop his nano armor.
But he's still a long ways off from that.
we get a brief shot of the outside of the Grand
Master's Tower
and all the statues of the previous winners
of the contest of champions.
The the same ones from Thor Ragnarok
It's man thing battery bill areas
by BS in dark crawler
we actually saw a man thing during werewolf by night
and even though Korg implies
that all the previous champions
in the contest of champions basically
just get killed by the grandmaster like if anybody wins
he'll just eventually kill them
Because man thing was still alive on earth.
After the events of Thor Ragnarok in the MCU,
that implies that like battery bill in this universe
is still potentially alive, for instance, or battery,
both still alive in the main 616
universe everybody wondering when they're going
to finally do him in the Marvel movies.
They'll probably do him eventually.
They actually did a version of the Beta
rebuild character in Thor Ragnarok,
but they got far along enough.
And Kevin Foggy, he was like,
You know, we'll just save him for a future movie.
So they got rid of all the Beta bill stuff
they'd already done Beta Ray.
Bill was also a big character
in the contest of champions during Planet Hulk,
which is a completely different story.
But a lot of Thor
Ragnarok was based on the plot of Planet Hulk.
that was why they initially included that Easter
egg here.
Iron Man learns
how Thanos was connected to the Qatari invasion
from Gamora and calls her Xena Warrior Princess.
Then it proved that he's a good person.
He decides to take down the Grand Master
before they stopped Thanos.
when Korg says paper is his nemesis, it's
meant to be a rock, paper, scissors
joke like the one they made during Thor Ragnarok
when he met Thor for the first time.
They also paid that joke off during Thor,
Love and Thunder,
when they saw the God of the Cronin's,
the ninny of the Noni who sits on a throne of scissors.
Tony says I am Iron Man again.
Korg references Tony's mother,
who's dead in this universe because in this reality,
Winter Soldier still killed his parents.
But he doesn't know it was Bucky yet.
we literally just saw an episode where there was like
an alternate version
of that storyline in his father wound up surviving.
they get valkyrie's help.
He makes a death race movie reference.
In that movie, they have a similar trope.
The context of champions in these cars
with a bunch of weapons.
They make a demon in a bottle reference,
which is a seminal Iron Man
comic book story about his alcoholism,
even though he's drinking in this episode.
That does seem like a weird moment.
Like why would he still be drinking
Valkyrie also claims
that that's the name of an actual type of booze here.
Like Demon in a bottle is an actual booze
that you can drink
Gamora melts, everyone with the stick
and cause not the burnt yarrow root.
That's the joke that they made in Thor Ragnarok.
there's another version of an Iron Man montage of him
making the trash buster suit.
And they use the same montage music
from the first Iron Man movie in the Even Mirror.
Some of the very specific shots like him
banging with the hammer in a shot on the goggles
they reveal that both Valkyrie in the Grandmaster know
all about Thanos in the Grand Master is afraid of him.
Iron Man makes a reference to Joseph
in the Technicolor Dreamcoat, which is a play.
and when they start their final battle race.
The Grandmasters car is designed to look like his ship
was in Thor Ragnarok, like a similar paint scheme
They make Iron Man
drive an actual chariot, paying off the reference
to the chariots from earlier in the episode.
And he makes a reference to his father, Howard Stark
and Atticus Finch from To Kill a mockingbird,
confessing to his daddy issues
and trying to bond with more over their bad dads.
He starts to win her over
during the course of the race.
And when he talks about the friend
that he lost, he's talking about Coulson
during the events of the Avengers movie R.I.P.
Coulson, even though he totally came back to Heidi.
It's a wonderful place.
They're a couple more Easter eggs
during their actual race.
Like when the course exits that giant building
that looks like the statue that's designed.
Kind of like a Jack Kirby style celestial.
Iron Man calls Gomora Lady Grinch
because she's green in his trash poster Armor forms
into a better race car powered by his arc reactor
that looks more like an actual Formula One car.
I'm pretty sure that Marvel is going to try to sell
some of this merchandise Like a while ago, they started
selling the actual trash poster armor, but I don't know
if they'll start selling the cars as toys do.
They'll be the Grand Master with Valkyries
help paying off
the Wizard of Oz reference
when he gets melted, making the Wicked Witch reference.
Iron Man makes Valkyrie king of Sakaar,
a reference to her being king of Asgard in the MCU.
Korg becomes her advisor and then Iron Man
and Gamora, a team out to kill Thanos by melting him.
R.I.P.
Josh Brolin came back to voice the character,
even though it was a very brief scene of him talking
Then after.
This is when they would have atomized
the infinity stones,
creating the infinity crusher device to atomized them
in, going back to the dwarves homeworld
to melt their version of the Infinity Gantlet.
Then we basically get that tag scene
that we saw of them in season one, Episode nine.
after that.
The idea I think is Iron
Man would have gone back to Earth around the time Iron
Man three would have been picking up, but
the plot of that would have gone down very differently.
It like, is it no more Infinity War, no endgame?
there be no Ultron.
So it'd be completely different plot.
But I think like my earlier idea,
they probably wind up fighting the Eternals
or the Celestials at some point.
That would be like the next big threat
they'd actually have to face.
the only downside to this too,
is because they don't have Ultron means that
vision does not get created, or if he does get created
is like a completely different circumstance.
In Scarlet Witch.
Quicksilver don't get experimented on the same way.
You have to imagine
like because there is no Age of Ultron.
Everything that led up to
that movie is completely different.
But then we get a surprise post-credits scene.
It's the second post-credits scene they've done this
season, so maybe we'll get more post-credits scenes in.
It's Topaz
collecting the puddle version of the Grand Master,
revealing that he's so powerful he's still alive.
He's just like a sentient puddle.
Now, like, put me in a bucket
they're a bunch of Easter Eggs
and references in the episodes that he spotted
Any that I didn't talk about in the video
Just write them below in the comments.
My Episode 5 video will post tomorrow
That'll be the Captain Carter Winter Soldier
episode in her universe
Paying off that Season 1 Post-Credits Scene.
click here for that video
I'll update the link as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other what if episodes
Thank you so much for watching, everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!